eu agriculture ministers have discussed
developments in europe's milk sector
weighing its long-term future with
quotas due to end next year
at their council in luxembourg the
european commission presented a report
on the so-called milk package which
entered force in 2012 and is meant to
cater for the sector's future
this is the last year of the quota
system the conditions on the market are
good
and that led to an overshoot of quotas
in many of the member states and those
member states believe that there needs
to be a smooth transition to a new
system
in order to avoid disruptions on the
market
now other member states are against
taking any measures whatsoever before
the quota system expires
because they believe that this would
penalize those who have actually stuck
to the rules for milk production the
supply of fruit vegetables and milk to
europe's schools was also on the menu
the ministers discussed work already
done towards new rules governing the aid
scheme for the supply of these foods
which have important nutritional
benefits for children
milk fruit and vegetable schemes were
introduced in europe in 1977 and 2007.
ministers voiced support for merging
them to increase efficiency and
effectiveness
fisheries ministers meanwhile took stock
of measures aimed at ensuring that
fishermen bring all their catches to
land and eliminating the practice of
discarding them at sea
the discard ban is one of the key
measures of the common fisheries policy
which was reformed last year and should
apply from early 2015.
the commission brief ministers on the
state of play of member states discard
plans prepared at the regional level
with new kinds of fish stocks to be
subject to landing obligations next year